wie pflanzt man heidelbeären so dass sie
einen richtig guten Ertrag abwerfen egal
ob im Kübel oder draußen im betet in
diesem Video verrate ich euch alle
heidelbeergeheimnisse für eine richtig
gute Ernte und das lohnt sich auch weil
wenn man alles richtig macht dann kann
so eine Pflanze 17 bis 20 Kilo Früchte
pro Jahr tragen also geben wir uns mal
besser Mühe ich habe vor ungefähr 10
Jahren meine ersten heidelbeären
gepflanzt und die sind alle eingegangen
ich habe nämlich einen riesengroßen
Fehler gemacht Blaubeeren sind nämlich
komplett anders als alle anderen
Pflanzen im selbstversorgergarten die
sind so anders dass man es bis vor 75
bis 80 Jahren nicht mal geschafft hat
die überhaupt anzubauen man hat damals
schon versucht die Wildform der
Blaubeere also die wilde Heidelbeere die
wir auch aus dem Wald kennen auszugraben
und zu Hause im Garten einzupflanzen und
genau wie bei mir bei meinen allerersten
blaubeerexerimenten sind diese Pflanzen
alle eingegangen ein amerikanischer
Botaniker hat dann zum Glück
herausgefunden woran das liegt und
dieses Wissen machen wir uns auch heute
zu Nutze wenn wir blaubeären bei uns im
Garten anbauen wollen Heidelbeeren
brauchen nämlich eine extrem saure Erde
eine Erde die so sauer ist dass die
allermeisten Pflanzen darin überhaupt
nicht wachsen könnten und genau das
müssen wir bei uns zu Hause auch
hinkriegen unsere Pflanzerde muss also
ein pH-Wert von 4 bis ungefähr 5,5 haben
das ist ein pH-Wert der sehr viel
niedriger ist als das wahrscheinlich bei
den allermeisten von euch bei euch im
normalen Gartenboden der Fall ist
natürlich gibt's da Ausnahmen vielleicht
wohnt ihr ja in Hüneburg und könnt mal
eure Erde testen da gibt so kleine
ph-wertstreifen mit dem man einfach
einen ph-werttest machen kann und
vielleicht habt ihr Glück und eure Erde
ist so sauer dass ihr da ohne Probleme
heidelbeären anbauen könnt aber die
aller allermeisten von uns müssen mit
morbid oder rododentron Erde nachhelfen
also sprechen wir mal über das
allerwichtigste beim heidelbäranbau die
Erde für Blumenerde wird super viel Torf
abgebaut das ist eine riesengroße
ökologische Katastrophe und deswegen
verwende ich für gemine Pflanzen auf dem
Balkon oder jetzt auch die haldeelbeären
immer nur torfreie Erde das ist in dem
Fall jetzt ein bisschen schwierig weil
ich habe es eben schon gesagt wir
brauchen eine morbederde also eigentlich
eine sehr torfaltige Erde damit unsere
blaubeären glücklich sind aber es gibt
mittlerweile sehr sehr gute
torfreduzierte mbeterden oder eben auch
komplett torfreie mbeterden also wenn es
irgendwie geht dann verwendet lieber so
eine Blumenerde und versucht möglichst
auf Torf zu verzichten ihr kennt ja
unseren wunderschönen Balkon und
natürlich wachsen die Pflanzen da
wunderbar aber ich würde trotzdem sagen
dass eigentlich jede Pflanze besser in
dem Beet wächst als im Topf einfach weil
die in dem Topf ja ein viel begrenzteres
wurzelvolumen hat und in dem betet frei
überall hin Wurzeln kann die Erde nicht
so schnell austrocknet und so weiter
also wenn man auf dem Balkon Gärtner hat
was ja wunderbar funktioniert aber dann
hat man ein paar mehr Herausforderungen
um seine Pflanzen glücklich zu machen
aber die Heidelbeere ist da eine
riesengroße Ausnahme ich habe euch ja
schon erzählt dass meine Heidelbeeren
die ich zuerst in meinem Garten
gepflanzt habe alle eingegangen sind und
als ich die ausgegraben habe die Toten
Grippe habe ich gesehen dass die Wurzeln
der Pflanzen nicht über den
ursprünglichen kleinentopf in dem ich
sie gepflanzt hatte hinausgewachsen sind
ich habe damals nämlich meine Erde nicht
aufgebessert weil ich damals eine arme
Studentin war und gedacht habe ich spar
mir die morbiderde ich habe da kein Geld
für ich mach es einfach so die Pflanzen
waren natürlich trotzdem teuer und am
Ende hatte ich nichts davon aber ich
habe mir damals gedacht h ich könnte ja
mit Dünger und m Rindenmulch die Erde
auf jeden Fall so nach und nach ein
bisschen saurer machen dass das schon
klappt aber Pustekuchen heidelbeären
sind wirklich super empfindlich wenn die
in diese alkalischere Erde reinwurzeln
dann hören die sofort auf weitere
Wurzeln zu bilden und das ist ein großes
Problem wenn man Heidelbeeren in ein
normalen Beet pflanzen möchte weil
rundherum ja die Erde ist die denen
nicht gut tut selbst wenn man ein Loch
greibt und da morbederde rein einfüllt
und dann die Heidelbeere reinpflanzt
kommen ja mit den Jahren immer noch
Regenwürmer die nach und nach die beiden
Substrate miteinander vermischen sass
das Substrat in der die Heidelbeere
wächst mit den Jahren immer schlechter
wird also immer weniger sauer sein wird
und deshalb ist die Heidelbeere so
ziemlich die einzige Pflanze die ich
kenne die in dem Topf besser aufgehoben
ist als draußen im Beet ich werde
trotzdem ein Beet anlegen und ein
bisschen tricken weil ich trotzdem nicht
nur topfheidelbeären haben will sondern
auch welche in meinem Bärengarten wie
das funktioniert zeige ich euch nachher
noch aber sprechen wir erstmal darüber
wie das ist wenn man heidelbeären in
einem normalen Blumentopf anbauen möchte
das ist eine Sorte die ziemlich groß
wird deswegen bekommt die auf jeden Fall
in den nächsten Jahren einen größeren
Topf z.B eine alte Zinkwanne oder ein
altes weinfast da gibt's ja auch richtig
schöne Optionen wenn ihr auf einem
Balkon gärtnert und da nicht so viel
Platz habt dann solltet ihr trotzdem
darauf achten dass der Topf mindestens
30 l groß ist was man auch beachten
sollte wenn man den Topf auswählt ist
dass heidelbeären eher Flachwurzler sind
das heißt so ein ganz ganz schmaler
hoher Topf ist nicht so gut geeignet
auch wenn der vielleicht genug Liter hat
wie einer der eher ein bisschen in die
Breite geht und bei allen Topfpflanzen
ist es natürlich wichtig dass der Topf
unten ein Loch hat also darauf auf jeden
Fall auch achten sonst bildet sich im
Topf staunessel das kann man auch
umgehen mit einer Dränageschicht ist
aber nicht so optimal also wenn ihr
wollt dass eure Pflanzen sich rund um
wohl fühlen auch wenn ihr mal ein
bisschen zu viel gegossen habt dann auf
jeden Fall ein Topf verwenden wo das
Wasser unten abfließen kann und dann
brauchen wir noch einen Langzeitdünger
den wir in die Erde einkneten es ist bei
heidelbeären super wichtig wie gesagt
das sind richtige Mimosen wenn es um den
pHWert geht dass man darauf achtet dass
jeglicher Dünger den man denen zuführt
nicht dazu führt dass die Erde
alkalischer wird also wir brauchen hier
einen rodudentron Langzeitdünger den wir
einfach mit in den Topf einarbeiten und
dann können wir die Pflanzen
reinpflanzen und zwar so dass das Level
des kleinen toopfes genauso ist wie das
Level des großen Topfes also von der
Erde her die einfach eben erdig
reinpflanzen bevor ich die in den Topf
setze lockere ich immer noch den
Wurzelballen auf weil das den Pflanzen
hilft ihr Wurzelwerk einfach weiter
auszubreiten im Topf und schneller viele
Wurzeln zu bilden aber wie gesagt nur
ganz ganz vorsichtig ohne die Pflanze
zudoll zu verletzen und dann ist es
natürlich wichtig gerade wenn man im
topfgärtnert aber sowieso eigentlich
immer die Pflanze zu mulchen dafür
verwende ich hier diesen Rindenmulch ich
sage immer wieder auch weil das viele
Leute in den Kommentaren Fragen
Rindenmulch hat im Gemüsegarten
eigentlich gar nichts verloren weil der
eigentlich viel zu sauer ist für die
ganzen Gemüsepflanzen die wir sonst so
anbauen aber heidelbeären wie gesagt
stehen da voll drauf deswegen decke ich
die Erde noch mit einer guten Schicht
von so 5 cm Rindenmulch ab und dann
gießen wir die Pflanze richtig schön an
gerade nach dem Pflanzen ist es wichtig
dass man der Eimer richtig viel Wasser
gibt damit die Erde richtig schön an die
Wurzeln geschlimmt wird und sich
eventuelle Hohlräume unter der Erde
schließen und dafür müssen wir
Regenwasser nehmen wieso das so wichtig
ist erkläre ich euch gleich noch wenn
wir über die Pflege der heidelbeären
sprechen aber jetzt gebt der erstmal
einen ordentlichen schwupp Regenwasser
wann ist denn die perfekte Zeit um
Heidelbeeren zu pflanzen fragt ihr euch
wahrscheinlich und da ist erstmal die
gute Nachricht dass das rund ums Jahr
geht die perfekte Pflanzzeit ist aber im
Herbst oder im Frühling vor allem weil
der Boden da schön feucht bleibt gerade
wenn ihr heidelberen draußen im Garten
pflanzen wollt also nicht im topfgärnern
wollt dann ist es natürlich praktisch
wenn man ein bisschen Hilfe von oben hat
und dann wä der Herbst und der Frühling
einfach durch den feuchten Boden die
beste Jahreszeit zum Pflanzen im Winter
wird's wahrscheinlich draußen im bet ein
bisschen schwierig wenn der Boden
geforen ist und weil ich jetzt so viel
darüber erzählt habe gehen wir mal rüber
und ich zeige euch mal wie ich das da
geplant und gemacht habe hier habe ich
ein blaubeärbeet in meinem neuen
Bärengarten angelegt und damit sich die
Pflanzen hier richtig wohl fühlen habe
ich ein bisschen getrixt man kann
einfach einen Graben ausheben den mit
morb mit Erde füllen und dann die
Pflanzen einfach dort hinein Pflanzen
weil wie ich eben schon erwähnt habe
vermischen sich ja dann mit den Jahren
der Mutterboden und die morbederde S
dass die Standortqualität für unsere
Pflanzen mit den Jahren leider immer
weiter abnimmt deswegen habe ich mir
diese alten maurerwannen hier geschnappt
die ich auf dem Hof gefunden habe wenn
du dir Sorgen machst dass aus
maurerwannen vielleicht giftige Stoffe
gelöst werden könnten ich habe im
Baumarkt auch Töpfe gesehen die genau
dasselbe Format haben ich wollte jetzt
einfach mal das nehmen was wir da haben
also habe ich Löcher reingebohrt damit
das Wasser abfließen kann und die dann
ebenerdig in den Boden eingegraben der
Pflanzabstand sieht jetzt sehr eng aus
das liegt daran dass ich dazwischen
preisebeären pflanzen möchte die
brauchen nämlich auch saure Erde und
sind ein richtig toller
mischkulturpartner für Heidelbeeren
deswegen habe ich zwischen den
Pflanzlöchern immer noch mal einen Loch
ausgehoben und dann kommt natürlich der
Langzeitdünger in die Erde und dann habe
ich in meinem Fall ein mulchflies geholt
das habe ich in der Scheune gefunden und
weil ich noch nicht so viel erfahr mit
mulchflies habe wollte ich das einfach
mal ausprobieren das ist ein Flies das
Gras und Unkraut unterdrückt aber Wasser
durchlässt an sich macht Gras und
Unkraut Heidelbeeren überhaupt nicht zu
schaffen also das ist nicht schlimm wenn
ihr das nicht habt ich wollte nur wie
gesagt einfach mal ein bisschen
experimentieren hier auf dem Hof und
dann ab in die Erde mit den Pflanzen die
preisebären habe ich immer dazwischen
gepflanzt und das ganze dann genau wie
im Topf richtig dickt mit Rindenmulch
gemulcht und ich habe hier auch noch
eine Beetumrandung aus Steinen gebaut
Rasenkante eing rben die verhindert dass
das Gras ins Beet wächst aber das muss
nicht sein ich fand das einfach nur
hübsch so ein richtiges kleines Beet für
meine Bären anzulegen und dann natürlich
richtig gut mit Regenwasser angießen
aber es gibt noch viel mehr über
heidelbeären zu sagen wir haben noch gar
nicht über den Standort gesprochen also
wo soll man denn so ein betet anlegen
oder wo stellt man den Kübel am besten
hin wenn man die im Topf anbauen möchte
heilbeeren brauchen schon relativ viel
Sonne also so mindestens 7 Stunden
direktes Sonnenlicht wären auf jeden
Fall nicht schlecht aber die sind
relativ empfindlich was Hitzestau angeht
da muss man also auf dem Balkon ein
bisschen gucken dass die vielleicht
sogar mit einem dünnen Netz oder so
schattiert werden weil die wenn die in
der pralensonne auf einem Südbalkon
stehen auch ein bisschen darunter leiden
könnten wir haben aus dem
gebrauchtwarenzentrum auf unserem Balkon
so eine spitzengardine gefunden die
haben wir z.B über ein paar Pflanzen
gespannt und das funktioniert perfekt
die Pflanzen bekommen immer noch richtig
viel Sonne durch die Löcher in der
Spitze aber sind auch ein bisschen vor
der pallensonne geschützt und bei
heidelbeären gibt's auch ganz
unterschiedliche Sorten meine
Lieblingssorte das ist auch die hier
heißt Elizabeth gerade wenn ihr mehrere
Sorten anbaut dann achtet mal darauf
wann die reif werden das steht auch
immer mit dabei es gibt frühe
mittelfrühe und späte Sorten und wenn
ihr das so ein bisschen staffelt dann
habt ihr einen viel größeren
Erntezeitraum die elizabeth ist übrigens
eine richtig richtig leckere Sorte also
geschmacklich mit einer der besten und
weil die für den industriellen Anbau
nicht so gut geeignet ist bekommt man
die auch eigentlich gar nicht im
Supermarkt ein Grund mehr für dieses
Schätzchen ihr könnt nur eine
heidelbergpflanze bei euch zu Hause
anbauen und ihr werdet davon Früchte
ernten wenn ihr alles richtig macht aber
der Ertrag wird noch mal deutlich größer
wenn ihr zwei unterschiedliche Sorten
anbaut wenn ihr zwei Pflanzen haben
wollt dann achtet auf jeden Fall darauf
dass die von zwei unterschiedlichen
Sorten sind ich habe bei mir im Garten
glaube ich drei unterschiedliche Sorten
das hilft einfach mit der Bestäubung und
dadurch hat man dann eine noch größere
Ernte der Unterschied zwischen den
wilden Waldheidelbeeren und den
kulturheidelbeären ist übrigens dass die
waldheidelbeären deutlich niedriger sind
also die Sträucher hier die werden
richtig richtig groß und die
waldheidelbeären bleiben ja auf jeden
Fall höchstens so kni hoch aber auch die
Früchte sind unterschiedlich die
Waldheidelbeeren sind inen blau und die
Kulturheidelbeeren nehmen wir mal
eine haben weißes Fruchtfleisch Bo die
sind so lecker und gleichzeitig noch
gesund es ist ja nicht oft so dass
Snacks einem auch noch gut tun aber
heidelbeären sind z.B toll für die
Zellerneuerung die bekämpfen
Entzündungen senken den Blutdruck
enthalten jede Menge tolle Vitamine Taus
Gründe warum man heidelbeären selber
anbauen sollte wenn wir die jetzt
gepflanzt haben wie gehen wir weiter mit
den Pflanzen um erstmal ist es super
super wichtig dass man Heidelbeeren nie
kalkt das hängt auch mit dem pH-Wert
zusammen wie gesagt auch wenn ihr düngt
dann verwendet Dünger die für sauren
Boden geeignet sind wir haben ja schon
den rododentron Dünger beim Pflanzen in
die Erde eingearbeitet aber natürlich
brauchen die Pflanzen wenn die in dem
Kübel wachsen auch immer mal wieder über
das Gießwasser einen Flüssigdünger
Flüssigdünger wirkt immer sehr viel
schneller auf die Pflanzen und ich
verwende dafür wie nasse die ist perfekt
geeignet für pflanzenin sauren Boden
mögen und auch für so ziemlich alle
anderen Gemüse im Garten das ist was was
ich sowieso da habe deswegen ist es für
mich super praktisch und ich weiß dass
auch ganz viele von euch mit wienasse
Gärtnern winasse ist auch ein
Abfallprodukt aus der Zuckerherstellung
also ein sehr nachhaltiger biologischer
Dünger der super schnell auf die Pflanz
wirkt und mit dem ich super Erfahrung
gemacht habe und dann sprechen wir mal
über das Gießwasser es kommt ganz drauf
an wie kalkhaltig euer Wasser bei euch
zu Hause ist das ist ja je nach Region
sehr unterschiedlich aber wenn ihr
kealkkaltiges Wasser habt dann ist es ja
ein bisschen wie Kalken ne haben wir ja
gerade rüber geredet deswegen ist es
super wichtig dass wenn ihr eure
Pflanzen gießt und ihr kalkhaltiges
Leitungswasser habt dass ihr dann auf
jeden Fall auf Regenwasser zurückgreift
das müsst ihr mal bei euch zu Hause
herausfinden wie kalaltig ist euer
Wasser ist das geeignet oder es gibt
eine Eigenschaft die heideelbeeren wenn
man sie einmal gepflanzt hat zu einer
der einfachsten Obstpflanzen im ganzen
Garten machen man muss die nämlich so
gut wie nie schneiden alle anderen
Pflanzen egal ob das jetzt Obstbäume
sind oder Johannesbeeren Himbeeren
wollen ja jedes Jahr geschnitten werden
damit ih einen guten Ertrag abwerfen
nicht so unsere Heidelbeeren da muss man
vielleicht nach 5 Jahren ungefähr mal
gucken ob so ein paar
vielleicht ein bisschen zu doll
ineinander wachsen und dann nimmt man
davon einen raus oder zwei aber im
Grunde muss man abgesehen von so einem
ausdönnungsschnitt alle paar Jahre
überhaupt nichts machen wichtig für
heidelbeären ist dass der Boden
gleichmäßig feucht ist also auch im Topf
immer mal mit dem Finger fühlen wenn man
sich durch den Mulch durchgekämpft hat
ob die Erde noch feucht ist und wenn
nicht dann auf jeden Fall gießen das
muss man in dem Topf natürlich öfter als
wenn man die in einem Kübel versenkt der
ein bisschen größer ist aber auch in
meinem Bärengarten werde ich mindestens
einmal pro Woche mit Regenwasser gießen
damit die Pflanzen rundum glücklich sind
heilb sind zum Glück richtig frosthart
also es ist gar kein Problem die auch
auf einem Balkon zu überwintern im Topf
was man machen kann ist dass man die im
Winter in so ein jutosack einpackt das
schadet auf jeden Fall nicht aber bei
mir ist bisher noch nie was passiert
wenn ich das vergessen habe es gibt
andere fröstte die schon problematischer
sein können das sind die Spätfröste im
Frühling wenn die Pflanzen blühen das
kann einem die ganze Ernte vermasseln
wenn die zu einem ungünstigen Zeitpunkt
kommen aber da kann man die Pflanzen
auch mit einem winterflies Schützen die
einfach schön einpacken und dann
hoffentlich dafür sorgen dass die Blüten
nicht erfrieren falls es noch mal so
spät im Jahr frieren sollte und dann
könnt ihr schon im ersten Sommer nach
der Pflanzung die ersten Bären ernten
das fängt natürlich langsam an also bis
so einen Strauch seine vollen bis zu 17
bis 20 kg trägt ver gehen 7 Jahre
ungefähr aber das ist doch richtig schön
dass man so schnell belohnt wird mit der
ersten eigenen Ernte und beim Ernten
muss man auch so ein paar Sachen
beachten erstmal werden nicht alle
Früchte gleichzeitig reif sondern nach
und nach das heißt wenn hier eure
Früchte hängen dann müsst ihr erstmal
nur die blauen Bären rauspicken und den
anderen noch ein bisschen Zeit geben das
Ernten erfordert also so ein bisschen
Fingerspitzen Gefühl und dann sollte man
die Heidelbeeren auch schön vorsichtig
pflücken weil das habt ihr bestimmt
schon mal gesehen Heidelbeeren haben
diese helle Schicht auf ihrer Schale und
wenn man die zu grob behandelt und die
Schicht abreibt dann werden die so
glänzend Blau das bedeutet aber dass die
viel kürzer haltbar sind die Haltbarkeit
wird dadurch so um drei Tage verkürzt da
also drauf achten dass ihr die
vorsichtig und wie gesagt mit
Fingerspitzen Gefühl pflückt damit das
nicht passiert und weil halbeären so
lecker sind muss man die auch oft vor
Vögeln beschützen weil die Vögel
natürlich kommen und sich die einen nach
dem anderen wegsmecken wollen falls ihr
Probleme mit Vögeln habt dann steckt
einfach einen Bambusstab zwischen eure
Pflanzen macht da einen Blumentopf
drüber oder sowas dann könnt ihr da
wunderbaren Netz drüber spannen dass die
ganze Pflanze einhüllt und vor den
hungrigen Vögeln beschützt es ist
natürlich längst nicht die einzige Beere
da draußen die man wunderbar selber
anbauen kann und die ganz viel
gartenglück bringt wenn ihr meine Videos
zu anderen bärensträuchern sehen wollt
dann schaut gerne da drüben vorbei da
verlinke ich euch die ansonsten geht
raus macht die Welt ein bisschen grüner
und wir sehen uns im nächsten Video
wieder bis dann tschüss ich Futter mich
jetzt hier durch